All right, today's new members of the day
are Dimitrios Minneapolis and John Hall.
Also, a big thank you to Susan Bruce.
Susan is today's longtime sustaining member
of the day.
Susan has been a member almost five years
dating all the way back to 2015.
Thank you all so much for your support.
Grab a membership as well as all of the great
perks that come with it at join Pacman dot
com.
It won't hurt a bit.
And it takes under a minute to sign up.
And it really does support the work that we're
doing.
OK?
We have to talk about the rapidly spreading
meme or demand or talking point, this idea
of abolish the police.
And this has basically three forms.
Sometimes it's literally abolish the police.
Sometimes it's defund the police.
And sometimes it's simply called A.S.A. be.
All cops are bastards.
Some version of this is essentially what we're
talking about here.
Now, I believe that this catchall is completely
miscalculated.
I believe it's inaccurate.
And I believe it dramatically helps Donald
Trump get reelected.
If it were to become a prominent theme of
Democrats, and I can't believe Joe Biden would
do it.
But if Joe Biden were to adopt this in the
time remaining between now and the election,
I'll tell you why.
And then we can talk about it.
We have a problem with police brutality in
the United States.
We have a problem with lack of proper training
for police.
We have a problem with militarized police
departments in this country.
We have a problem with lack of police accountability
in the United States.
We are seeing overwhelmingly peaceful protests
demanding that these issues be dealt with.
And that's a beautiful thing.
They were catalyzed by the horrific killing
of George Floyd in Minneapolis.
And protests like this and rallies like these
have not been seen in the United States for
a long time.
And it is a great thing.
But abolish the police, defund the police.
Sometimes the messaging can seem inspirational
or catchy, but it doesn't actually make any
sense.
And it's not popular.
And it is a huge risk.
If the left is going to adopt this as part
of a platform heading into November, abolish
or defund the police is using a sledgehammer
when what you need is a velvet glove.
And I'll explain why and I'll defend my position
on this.
And then if you disagree, I want to hear from
you.
The problem is just not as simple as police
have too much money.
And if we take the money away, we solve the
problem.
The problem is not as simple as police need
to be eliminated.
And then we would be much better off, including
replacing police altogether with social service
agencies or community watch groups or whatever
the case may be.
The problem is sometimes too much police funding
for the wrong things.
The problem is sometimes lack of training.
The problem is not enough funding in some
cases, and that can actually be the cause
of the problems we're trying to solve.
So let's just get really specific about it.
Let's start with one example.
Many police departments have become militarized
like armies.
This is something I talked about last week
and I mentioned last week, and this is superimportant
police training in the United States is too
short and doesn't deal with how police officers
should actually be trained to be better stewards
of their communities and to de-escalate situations
rather than escalate situations in many countries,
police training as much longer than in the
United States.
That costs more money.
But that extra training should not be focused
on riot control with rubber bullets.
It should instead be social work type training.
If police were trained more like social workers
and less like soldiers, if police were equipped
with de-escalation tools rather than military
vehicles, then we would eliminate many of
the disastrous outcomes that we have because
the first instinct of more police would be
to de-escalate rather than to say, is this
a time to pull a gun or to use a Taser, Taser
or to pull out a nightstick or baton or shield
or police a militarized military vehicle.
But the reality is that could cost more money.
It could cost more money to better trained
police for longer.
If you double the amount of time police officers
spend in training from 13 to 26 weeks.
It's likely that is going to cost more money,
not less.
And so the sledgehammer of abolish the police
or defund the police fails to actually achieve
what we want.
I mentioned militarization when a police department
is militarized.
They see themselves more like a military force
than as members of the community, and they
solve problems with the tools that they have.
Again, shields, military type vehicles.
Riot control tactics, pepper pepper spray
balls and the like.
In this case, we need to demilitarize the
police.
Now, you might do that by strategically cutting
funding for certain types of training and
equipment in order to achieve the demilitarization
of police.
Beautiful.
Brilliant.
I'm all for it.
But again, defund the police or abolish the
police does not actually leave us better off.
Now, in some police departments, the problem
is they don't have enough funding.
They can't hire enough officers.
They can't do community activism and involvement.
So when a police department is underfunded,
they resort to the cheap policing of what
we call low hanging fruit.
If you are underfunded and police aren't properly
trained and you don't have the resources,
you need to get police involved in the community,
you basically just send up tons of cops to
poor areas.
You send the cops, you have to poor areas.
And as we know, those areas are disproportionately
nonwhite and they hang out there.
Maybe they do stop and frisk or similar type
tactics and then they just rack up arrests
simply by saying, you know, we we don't.
We send people to the areas where we believe
there is the most crime.
And of course, because that's the only area
they are in, they find crime there and nowhere
else.
And it gets up there, arrest numbers.
And it's the self-fulfilling prophecy, prophecy
that we know so, so well.
So that's an example where the police department
might actually be better if they were better
funded not to get shoulder mounted RPG eyes
and riot gear, but to actually have proper
levels of staffing, to be involved in the
community, to be trained in de-escalation
like social workers.
Let me give you one more example of this.
A lot of police are policing places where
they don't live.
And in fact, sometimes there's a big divide
where you have officers who live in rural
areas outside of a city policing an urban
area.
And this is not a good thing for a number
of different reasons.
When you bring when you have community members
policing their communities, you typically
are going to be much better off because you
don't have outsiders coming in.
The people in the community are going to be
better disposed to the police because it's
not these outsiders from some other place
who just come in and do whatever.
And then they leave and they sleep somewhere
else at night.
And you are going to have police officers
that are more actually taking a stake in the
long term effects of their policing rather
than just doing the easy stuff, the low hanging
fruit.
As I mentioned, but in big cities, you might
need more funding in order to do that.
The reason a lot of police don't live where
they are working is it's too expensive.
So this is not me saying give everybody raises,
you know, umbrella.
But the point is, in order to achieve something
that would improve, a lot of police departments
require some percentage of the force to live
in the area that they police, it might not
be cheaper.
You may not be able to do that simply by defunding.
So I am as disgusted and enraged as you are
by the horrifying videos of sick police brutality
from the last 10 days of protests.
My question is, is defunding or abolishing
police really going to solve the problem?
Now, a couple other things that I want to
mention.
We should have a central database of bad police
actors so that when there are complaints and
when there are dismissals, it's harder for
an officer to hide that when they go and apply
somewhere else.
And it's harder for the new to police department
to say we had no idea.
You have a central database of bad police
actors.
The unions will likely oppose this.
It would be a fight, but it would cost money
to maintain such a database.
Civilian review, review boards for police,
use of force complaints and police shooting.
Some cities have done this.
That can cost money.
Mandatory police body cameras that can cost
money.
Now, hopefully you'd be able to reallocate
funding away from militarization and towards
cameras, et cetera.
But again, the catch all of abolish or defund
does not take into account any of these details.
One last thing here.
As Progressive's, we should before government
and state involvement where it makes sense.
We want the government involved in health
care, for example.
There are not enough involved right now.
We want the government involved in regulating
industry.
They do not regulate themselves effectively
when it comes to law enforcement.
We actually want government doing it and not
the people because the people sounds nice
when you imagine neighborhood watches and
and how that will work.
But you have two problems.
First.
The people in your neighborhood quickly become
some private security firm with the best lobbyists
and can get the most weapons.
You know, Google cops, you get free with ads.
But to get better service, get Amazon Prime
police.
And by the way, it comes with being able to
watch some TV shows for free as well.
We don't want that.
It will become the police equivalent of private
prisons or.
Private mercenary firms that fight wars overseas
for us.
It's not the progressive option.
Secondly, there is no denying that sometimes
you actually need the scope of state and government
missile defense as a private endeavor where
neighborhoods decide here's how we're going
to defend ourselves from missile attacks.
Doesn't really work well.
And in the case of policing, you need these
state and federal law enforcement resources
to deal with things that are big, like human
trafficking.
It's too big and too complex for communities
and private industry to deal with human trafficking
and the global, federal, state and local elements
that need to be combined.
So the solution that is progressive is not
defund or abolish the police.
It's elect the right people to fix the police,
ensure that the police are working for us
in the way that we want.
And you do that in part by electing the right
people to make those decisions change.
The mayor changed.
The governor changed the police chief.
Now, one more thing.
Should other areas have more funding?
Yes.
Do we need more funding for teachers and education?
Of course.
Do we need more funding for public health
and public housing and homelessness?
And of course, we do.
That is a separate issue from defund or abolish
the police.
Absolute last thing on this, defund the police
is being hugely boosted by bots online because
they know it's divisive.
And I hate to tell you that it'll help Trump
defunding the police as of two days ago, has
16 percent support in this country.
It's very low.
There is more support than ever for reforming
the police.
We previously discussed that it makes sense
in 2018 for Democrats to run on abolish ice,
even if you support it.
I don't believe that that would have been
logical in 2018.
I see no evidence that abolish the police
is a good platform, and I believe that it
will help Donald Trump to get reelected.
If Joe Biden were to adopt it, it would dramatically
hurt his chances of winning in November.
If this is still a very prominent issue at
that point, tell me whether you agree or disagree.